On the other hand, our vision still has a lot of developing to do after we're
born. A newborn can only see at about 20-600, which isn't great at all
considering that 20-20 is perfect vision. Objects need to be really close to a
baby for them to be able to see it. It's not until at about age three or four
when vision is similar to that of an adult. An interesting point to make is
that newborns aren't great at seeing color. Our eyes have to develop in order
for us to see color. Remember the rods and the cones in the eye? Our cones need
to develop and merge to the center of the retina for us to see color in detail.
When we were born, we primarily use our rods, which allow us to see black or
white or light and dark. This is why babies are so fascinated with high
contrast black and white designs. And when we get older, we use our rods and
our cones.